[Music]
all who here has an Apple Watch anybody
I used to I have I'm I am I the only one
I used to have one but it would die
every 20 minutes I'm familiar with how
it works are you going to get radiation
I don't know
man cuz you know Italy just uh baned
watch off his [__] he's like [__]
MN you know you know uh they just Bann
the iPhone 12 in Italy or whatever is
because of the radiation levels really I
think it's Italy so they banned the old
phone man it's one of those European
countries you know how they're more
healthc conscious than we are yeah well
I think it took some time you know cuz
you got to go iPhone 12 is dangerous and
then they got to put it into [__]
government and they take a long time
three four years guys are so lazy right
so then 10 years later they go we're
going to ban it and then it finally goes
into play and then now we're on the 15
yeah so too late wait but maybe it was
just one year it's like when they recall
like the Honda Civic 2019 you know what
I mean they're like just don't use that
year it could be cuz Apple says well we
already got an update and then we fix
that software
glitch and software is different dude
the radiation levels is too much there's
too much our dicks are [__] so what
about the apple good to bring it back I
was just excited that we're talking
about dick so early again yeah dude I'm
sorry guys back to back said uh there
was a woman in Michigan right she had
dropped her Apple watch in an ouse oh in
a
cocka so she decided it was too valuable
and she needed to go get it oh Slum Dog
Millionaire [__] she climbed that's good
reference she climbed into this out
house to get her apple wash but then she
got stuck you could climb inside of a
out house well she just [__] in a
pile of [__] o why does she have the the
most technologically advanced thing in
the most UN technologically advanced
Place yeah that's actually a very good
point how does that even work that's a
very very good question visiting a uh it
was a a Dixon Lake Area apparently um so
I'm guessing she was just visiting this
area for you know recreational purposes
and you know sometimes you go camping
you find yourself in place behind a a
tree yeah well if there's an out house
usually you but you can drop for Apple
watch in there how do you drop the Apple
watch yeah and how come she doesn't have
a hand claw close
by these
moments I knew this would come in handy
one day he's got stuff for like 15 years
he never uses until one day worth it y
so First Responders were called when the
woman was heard yelling for help and she
didn't have a hand
claw the toilet was removed and a strap
was used to haul the woman out oh [__] I
mean dude she did she find her iPhone I
watch though Apple watch I hope she did
I think she got it yeah she retrieved
her watch before her rescue so yeah I
think it worked maybe she used the watch
to call for rescue she didn't counter
steps dude that's why she o she must
have been smelling like cocka that is
one of the most useful things that I use
my Apple watch for for sure step counter
oh yeah dude that's so crazy though like
you care about your Apple watch like
sometimes like I'll drop my phone in
between my car seat and I'm like it's
gone
forever that's it I got to go [__] I
got to go get a new one
I'm come on dude pick up the car phone
hey I need a new
phone a car what is what do I have a 95
Beamer a Carbone you're anmo this idea
of luxury is like 40 years ago some of
us are economy class for life right guys
fun so high up top yeah yeah yeah stop
punching down guy yeah dude I don't know
the new [__]
huh my idea of splurging is when I get
to choose which seat I can be in I pay
extra $10 for
that back to the airports okay we're
back airplane thing that's a happy place
we get it you like
airport I'm looking up hand claws right
now hold on so that's the that's how the
uh afterward she got out of her uh Kaka
shitty situation she took a swim in the
lake and that's how it turned into Lake
TI Kaka
stupid [__] does he do this a lot
sometimes yeah every day if you Dro if
you dropped your Apple watch in there
would you leave it bro how is this a
hand claw this I I Googled hand claw and
this [__] popped up you know what I was
talking about I know you was talking
about I'm just okay like TI Kaka like a
TI
Kaka this is crazy why did she just go
in the forest and get a [__] long
stick and try to fish it out probably
like going down into the [__] oh my God
what a stupid [__] am I right who I
didn't go that far what a stupid [__]
she just didn't make a good decision
that day and she could probably do a lot
of things okay the Apple watches are
expensive they're expensive would you
leave it if if it was that type of
situation what would you do I would not
leave it but I wouldn't crawl in there
someone else's [__] too cuz there's
other people's [__] in there bro you
just you got to take the L dog that's
why you can't wear anything too
expensive I'm [__] finding some ROP
in V I'm finding a stick and I'm
figuring out how to fish that [__] out
I'm not [__] crawling in there but
I'm not leaving it yeah so I don't know
what the answer is but somewhere it's
going to happen but those things are so
small how doeses she fit in there that's
why she got it wasn't it wasn't it's an
OU house don't think of Porter
potty it's an OU house I go to ouses in
Las
Vegas okay yeah where he's like at the
wind there's one in the
wind nobody knows about it like uh the
hiking trails you go into the bathrooms
and then you look it's just the it's
just a toilet that goes straight to the
yeah and then it's pretty big who cleans
up that [__] I think guys come and they
pump it like it's like um there's like a
cocka reservoir on the bottom Co like a
septic tank or whatever that's
somebody's job for sure but it doesn't
flush it's like a porta potty but like
stationary yeah you go up to that guy
doing that you're like do you want to
play the harp he's like yes please get
me the [__] out of here I [__]
anything I think they make a lot of
money y for sure they do cuz they
probably do every little like and they
have great benefits yeah for sure yeah
is that is is that true because a lot of
time like when people would grow up and
they would be like oh I don't like you
could be you're going to be a garbage
man if you don't get your [__] together
and then obviously people were like um
well garbage men actually make a lot of
money great benefits did we ever find
like someone said that to you growing up
see I knew some people yeah and actually
I knew some I know somebody that I
reconnected with in high school and
their Waste Management he he's he
actually picks the trash cans on our
block by the G I think they like six
figures good he good for them because I
thought people were lying to me you that
happened to you guys growing up too or
am I wrong no I heard it people say that
[__] okay I was just I was just
wondering if it was maybe it's more East
Coast thing though garbage man Salin La
what the [__] is 11 Grand to
178,000 Big how good that's everything
every job
ever maybe really part time Google May
he's a part-timer yeah la is interesting
or maybe we know nothing yeah but you
know there is a shortage of blue collar
work so yeah because everyone wants to
be on [__] Tik Tok now I'm on Tik Tok
follow me jny I got 1.1 million follow
but everyone wants to be on [__] Tik
Tok now like yeah why not dude any guys
that learn construction skills being an
electrician whatever they're going to
they're going to in the next 10 years
they're going to [__] rake in that
money dude rake it in but all dudes want
to be makeup artists and [__] or Tik Tok
like [__] be makeup artists yeah they
don't I don't know any dudes that are I
don't know maybe three you know a lot
yeah a lot of guys just they're like I
ain't picking up a hammer that's just
too heavy yeah I'll paint these eyebrows
though like I get injured dude yeah I'll
Contour that those cheek bus yeah dude
jeny guys they're like I'm going be my
own boss and I'm going [__] be a
crypto guy or whatever right and then
they see a hammer and they're like I'm
allergic to fixing things yeah I'm going
to hire that out you know that's what
they do and pay in Bitcoin pay in
Bitcoin pay in bit Yeah but anybody that
does that they're going to make a lot
somebody that learned how to make a
bridge and fix it they're going to make
a lot or people that come and and clean
up [__] in Waste Management I bet that's
a lot dude how many people are you
competing that's true always and it's
always going to need to be managed and
no one's no one's going to want to do
that job no real talk though a lot of
this [__] like our roads Bridges
everything they're like they need to be
maintained right but all the dudes that
built it the Boomers and all that [__]
they're like going to die or retire and
there's not enough from Millennials to
like down to replace all those roles so
now we're going to be like
robots [__] Lil huie's going to be
out there like trying to fix it he's a
Tik tocker you guys know okay cool sorry
that was a yeah some of the fans will
probably get who's Lil huie dude dude
I'm sorry you guys are all 50 and you
don't [__] know I am pretty old sorry
okay go on what were you saying why is
it that there's uh money that goes to
like Waste Management like that and I
know there's a reason why but like you
know there's no money that goes into
like picking up trash from like the the
oceans and stuff like that you always
need like Charities to donate to that
kind of [__] cuz nobody wants that
doesn't make money yeah and it doesn't
it like the bridges and stuff impedes
people's lives like out of sight out of
mind like we don't see it we don't
experience it in our daily life so we're
not going to pay tax dollars towards it
right yeah no [__] way or maybe the
volume is too crazy crazy the amount of
like [__] that's being thrown in the
ocean is just we have trash Islands yeah
versus the hike [__] Trails there's not
that many people hiking got that giant
initiative with the [__] two boats
that have like that giant [__] net
that picks up trash from the the plastic
whatever they they call it in the in the
Pacific and stuff like that but it's
always like you got to like donate money
to those causes and stuff but over here
we're like yeah dude Waste Management
people get like six figure salaries and
benefits yeah well I think it's you know
just because someone has to pay for it
to be clean we're paying people six to
come pick up our trash from our house
and throw it in just go out to the near
Ocean and just throw it out
there you think they recycle these
bottles no we just put in the ocean yeah
who do you think's throwing it in the
ocean that guy that that guy that you
know is literally throwing it into the
ocean [__] shut up cam dude [__] the
turtles